dans ce bar de washington les bouteilles
de rhum accumule la poussière sur les
tablettes chez cause il est fermé depuis
le début d'épidémie
mais derrière ces portes closes la
distillerie cotten reid fourmille
d'activités les employés s'affairent à
préparer et à mettre en bouteille
la dernière cuvée non pas du rhum mais
du désinfectant pour les mains une
transformation radicale pour cette robe
gris artisanale une question de survie
ça permet de payer les employés les
factures et loyers explique john carter
le des deux fondateurs distillerie a
rapidement été débordée au début
explique t-il n'avions pas réalisé
l'ampleur de la demande
nous avons fait quelques litres pour
aider les gens et deux semaines plus
tard je me retrouve avec un réservoir de
7500 litres plein des effectifs
désinfectant contient du peroxyde de
l'aude et glycérine
mais aussi bien sûr de l'iphone
auparavant c'était du rhum à 90% produit
dans cet alambic mais incapable de
répondre à la demande
les employés de la distillerie ont dû se
résigner et se tourner vers de l'éthanol
industriels
tous les jours les clients font la queue
devant la distillerie pour se procurer
le précieux liquide donc riches viennent
ici pour la deuxième fois
j'aime acheter local dit il et il est
très difficile de trouver du
désinfectant ailleurs c'est un produit
qui peut sauver des vies croit pour sa
part anne ou pottow elle en a acheté
deux bouteilles pour son fils quoi c'est
à new-york narguer dit elle pas de
masque pas de lingettes pas de
désinfectant il est coincé chez lui en
fait seule une petite portion de la
production de la distillerie est vendu
l'essentiel est donnée à des cliniques
et à des oeuvres de charité
on se sent utile du tour donne on est
dans une position on peut vraiment aider
et faire le bien
pourtant le patron de la distillerie et
les employés n'espère qu'une chose le
retour à la normale on rêve du moment où
l'on va pouvoir recommencer à faire du
rhum dit il des cocktails et s'amuser
car bien sûr cela voudra dire que le
coronavirus n'est plus qu'un mauvais
souvenir
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
washington